we have some breaking news from South
Korea South Korea's military says that
North Korea launched two short-range
missiles toward Japan they were
reportedly fired from North Korea's
eastern region right into the Sea of
Japan
now japan's Prime Minister is calling it
a threat to Japan and saying it's also a
threat to the international community
ramie Inocencio is in South Korea right
now he says he has more discounts as the
13th projectile launched by North Korea
this year Seoul's Joint Chiefs of Staff
said those projectiles were launched
from a province on the northeast coast
the move appears to be an attempt by the
north to pressure the White House to
make concessions in nuclear talks which
have been in a deep freeze South Korea's
military together with the United States
is monitoring the area for more launches
meanwhile North Korean ally China is
reacting furiously to a move by US
President Trump in Hong Kong
anti-government protesters are
celebrating what they call a moral
victory after the President signed the
Hong Kong human rights and democracy Act
that law passed with a veto-proof
bipartisan majorities in both the House
and Senate allows the White House to
sanction Chinese and Hong Kong officials
and organizations based in the former
British colony if civil liberties are
violated the Hong Kong government has
called it unwarranted Beijing has called
the act hegemonic and doomed to fail
this morning China's summoned the US
ambassador to protest that move for CBS
this morning
ramie Inocencio Seoul